[Música]
una vez más les doy la bienvenida al
espacio de cultura de france 24 el cine
para dejar huellas y participar en la
memoria colectiva de un país es el
propósito del documental el estallido
sobre el paro nacional del año pasado en
colombia la película explica las raíces
de este masivo movimiento social y
mayoritariamente pacífico y relata con
los testimonios de sus actores
principales la violenta represión por
parte del estado meses de documentación
en el terreno durante estas protestas
históricas y también un meticuloso
trabajo de verificación de imágenes para
llegar a este retrato o más bien estos
retratos de las muy diversas voces del
movimiento pobreza desempleo falta de
acceso a la universidad
asesinatos de líderes sociales
desplazamientos forzados desapariciones
los problemas denunciados durante el
paro de 2021 siguen siendo relevantes
hoy y por eso el estallido se estrena
esta semana en la capital bogotá unos
meses antes de las elecciones
presidenciales veamos el trailer
la gente que plantea que prefieren salir
a que los mates es claro porque es que
aquí estamos los nadies
se da a la movilización pacífica más
extraordinaria en muchísimas décadas
y una ciudadanía que además está digamos
anhelando un cambio
[Aplausos]
[Música]
de un país de espectro y es que quien
llegue a ocupar la presidencia de 2022
sabe que tiene una ciudadanía organizada
capaz de organizar su rabia y de
convertir su rabia en el reclamo punto
el documental será proyectado en varias
ciudades de colombia y en unas semanas
estará disponible en línea dólar e
información se puede encontrar en el
sitio web el estallido puntocom contar
una historia de lucha y de resistencia
es también el propósito del escritor y
periodista italiano roberto saviano con
su fascinante novela gráfica todavía
estoy vivo tal vez lo conocen por su
novela investigación gómora sobre el
mundo de la magia de nápoles un éxito
mundial vendido en millones de
ejemplares y adaptado como serie y que
cambió la vida de sabiendo para siempre
porque la magia ha jurado desde entonces
vengarse como resultado fue puesto bajo
protección policial durante dos semanas
que se transformaron en 15 años hasta
hoy roberto saviano narra esta vida
amenazada en una obra que mezcla
relato biográfico clásico con los
dibujos creativos del israelí asafa
nunca quedan contenidos a sus emociones
y sensaciones
algunos artistas les gusta dibujar en
hojas de papel mientras que otros
prefieren la grandeza de las paredes de
una ciudad desde los años 90 la
megalópolis de sao paulo y sus 22
millones de habitantes abrazan el arte
callejero hace poco unos artistas se
inspiraron en la pandemia del
coronavirus para crear obras que como lo
explican rinden homenaje al personal
sanitario art
durante pandemia de un papel durante la
pandemia el arte callejero desempeña un
papel muy importante en la
sensibilización varios artistas hicieron
campañas actos de solidaridad otros
donaron obras a los hospitales
poco sabíamos muy poco del cob y así que
fueron estos profesionales los que
acabaron dando esperanza a los enfermos
así que creo que se trataba
principalmente de eso retratar a una
persona que tiene ese halo de luz como
si fuera realmente la persona que aporto
esperanza a la gente un cierto confort
una sensación de seguridad y pausado
como asegurados hay paz al otro lado del
océano tres meses después de que francia
devolviera 26 obras
el publico beninés puede por fin
descubrir estos tesoros del reino de
abomey en el palacio de la marina en
cotonou después de
129 años lejos de su país la exposición
'arte de benin ayer y hoy también hace
honor a la creación contemporánea para
ofrecer una visita en forma de diálogo
entre artistas de diferentes
generaciones
nos quedamos en el continente africano
con el nuevo videoclip del príncipe de
la rumba congoleña felipe para el
cantante y bailarín es una estrella en
áfrica y hace parte de la nueva
generación adentro de este estilo
musical que viene de la rumba cubana de
los años 30 conocido por su voz sus
canciones que hablan de amor feliz y
para estreno 100 esta semana
soy yo
otros
[Música]
y cantar sobre las relaciones es también
cantar sobre la necesidad de terminar
para empezar de nuevo en el líder tuyo
ex carta a tu ex la cantautora británica
amalia se inspiró de una pelea con su
novio para escribir una canción pidiendo
a una ex novia de dejarles en paz
pezzotta
2a m del grupo británico de rock shows
tiene también una letra catártica
hablando de ciclos repetitivos de
comportamientos destructivos pero a la
vez es la canción perfecta para encender
las pistas de baile y esperar el séptimo
disco de la banda life is words
[Música]
[Aplausos]
nos despedimos de vuelta en américa
latina con el nuevo tema de osuna
deprimida y un videoclip en el que el
dominicano se divierte paseando por
platós de cine en plano secuencia
gracias por seguirnos y cuídense
[Música]
s
no señor la volpe se que vas a volver
estas cosas que lo conocen y yo lo
conozco de él que es el deprimido
estas dolido
cada vez que te vayas